If you want to see how deep and long lasting
the current Republican Party delusion or lies,
depending on what you think about them, about the
20 20 presidential election are going to last. I
have very bad news for you. It looks like the
denialism, delusion and lies about the twenty
twenty election are going to last for a very
long time. I have video for you from yesterday
of top House Republican Steve Scalise. He's the
House minority whip or whip, as some say. He went
on ABC's This Week. He was interviewed by host
Jonathan Karl and asked a very simple question.
Are you ready to say? The election wasn't stolen.
Are you ready to say that Donald Trump didn't
really win in a landslide, as he claims, and that
Joe Biden simply won? He got more votes in enough
states to get more than two hundred and seventy
electoral votes? Steve Scalise was asked this
question. Listen to the equivocation. Listen
to the language choices of Steve Scalise. This
is almost March. We are almost four months from
this election and Steve Scalise just won't stop.
But clear this up for me.
Joe Biden won the election.
He is the legitimate president of the United
States. The election was not stolen. Correct.
Look, Joe Biden's the president, there were a
few states that did not follow their state laws,
that's really the dispute that you've seen
continue on. And look, if you're Joe Biden,
you probably want to keep talking about
impeachment and anything other than the fact
that he's killed millions of American energy jobs.
That is a twenty nine second clip, half of which
is the anchor talking. And still in 15
seconds, Steve Scalise manages to slip in.
Look, Joe Biden is the president, which is
that's a sort of dog whistle. That's code for
he is the president, but he didn't win.
Understand the careful vocabulary choices there.
Scalise says there were states that didn't follow
their own state laws by which he means too many
people who wanted to vote were able to vote, and
nobody stopped them with the voter suppression
that we were planning. And then he says Joe Biden
would rather keep talking about impeachment. No,
he wouldn't. Joe Biden hasn't been talking about
impeachment since being sworn in. Every time Biden
is asked about impeachment, he says, I'm not
involved. I wasn't in the Senate when this was
done. I had nothing to do with the House vote. I'm
not getting involved since impeachment. Joe Biden
also hasn't been talking about it. Joe Biden seems
to have no interest in talking about impeachment.
Then it continues. And Jonathan Karl tries again
to get a straight answer that he continues to.
They just signed the Paris accord. It's
going to kill manufacturing jobs in America.
But at the end of the day, when you look at
where we are in this country, either we're going
to address the problems that happened with the
election, that people are still millions of people
are still concerned about. The Constitution says
state legislatures set the rules for elections.
That didn't happen in a few states. And so
going forward, like Joe Biden became president.
But I mean I mean, I towards what people
are angry about. But one congressman I know,
Joe Biden is the president. He lives at the
White House. I asked you, is he the legitimate
president of the United States? And do you
concede that this election was not stolen?
Very simple question, please. Just once.
Once they elect, once the electors are
counted. Yes, he's the legitimate president.
But if you're going to ignore the fact that
there were states that did not follow their
own state legislatively set laws once the
electors voted, he's the legitimate president.
But and and of course, there what he means
is the electors in some states voted for the
person who didn't really win. In some states,
Biden got the electoral vote, but he hadn't
actually won the popular vote in those states.
These are the continued dog whistles. There's a
little bit more. Let's take a quick look at it.
That's the issue at heart that millions of people
still are not happy with and don't want to see
happen again. You know, look, you can rehash
the election from two thousand and twenty all
day long, but there are people concerned about
what the next election is going to look like.
Are we going to finally get back to the way the
rule of law works? And I think that's the biggest
frustration many people have, is those states
that didn't follow the law. Are they going to
keep doing that in the future? Are we going
to finally get back to what the Constitution
calls out for electing our leaders?
Imagine saying, as Steve Scalise,
a ranking Republican, says, that what people
want with elections is to get back to the
rule of law. Despite Democrats, Trump lost
claimed victory at two a.m. on election night,
ran a two month campaign claiming it was stolen
and that he won in a landslide. Had lawyers
try more than 50 legal complaints, none of which
went anywhere. Still refused to concede and then
incited a riotous insurrection at the Capitol on
January 6th. And Steve Scalise says we need to get
back to the rule of law. We'll talk to your own
party, talk to people like Josh Hawley and others.
It's just stunning. And then, oh, it separately
from this same interview, the topic of January 6th
does come up. And Jonathan Karl points out
Trump still hasn't taken any responsibility for
his role in inciting that riot. Check out
the mental gymnastics Scarless does here.
Just as difficult to get an answer on this one.
But but wait a minute. I mean, he hasn't taken
responsibility. You heard Kevin McCarthy say
I mean, do you agree with what Kevin McCarthy
said there, that the president must take
responsibility, that the facts demand,
that he take responsibility for
what happened on January 6th?
Well, first of all, I know I wrote a Wall
Street Journal editorial about where I think the
responsibility lays for January 6th. And surely
there's a lot of blame to go around. But at the
end of the day, the people who stormed the Capitol
on January 6th, it was a disgrace. And they need
to be held accountable. And in fact, over one
hundred and eighty have already been arrested. And
I know the FBI is working to root out every person
who broke into the Capitol, who attacked police.
I mean, that's that's obvious, I'm asking about
Donald Trump's role in this, you heard again,
Kevin McCarthy. Do you agree with what
he said, that he bears responsibility
for what happened, for what happen again?
You can go back. You can go back and look at
the impeachment trial, the second impeachment
trial. It seems like all they've done since
they walked into office was try to impeach
him. But again, when you look at that trial,
they ran a clip of pretty much every United States
senator who voted to impeach President Trump,
who talked about things like go and fight
like hell and other things like that.
Even the simplest of questions he will not
answer if they would put any kind of blame
on Donald Trump, he simply won't do it. And Steve
Scalise is remaining as one of the most steadfast
defenders of Donald Trump. Absolutely.
No matter what period. End of story. So
the message is, if you thought they'd stop
defending him anytime soon. Not so. And the
reason we care about this is not because we need
to be reminded again that these people don't care
about law and order and don't care about the truth
or reality or facts or empiricism or the world as
it actually exists rather than as they wish that
it would be. The reason this matters is that if
they still won't even concede that Trump actually
did lose, they aren't going to be anything but
complete and utter obstructionists for the
foreseeable future. Which reinvigorates my thought
that it's time to stop waiting on Republicans
for covid stimulus. It's time for Democrats
to pass it via budget reconciliation. Let every
single Republican, if they want to vote against
it and put themselves at risk of the electoral
consequences if their constituents don't like it.
But these are the people we're waiting around for.
The guy who still won't say
Trump had something to do with the insurrection
and still won't say Trump simply lost. These
people can't be counted on for anything and
it's time to just move forward without them.